foreign
ERS of Ramsay Solutions broadcasting
from the pots Moving and Storage Studio
it's the Ramsay show we're dead as Dom
cash is king and the paid off Home
Mortgage has taken the place of the BMW
as the status symbol of choice we help
people build wealth do work that they
love and create actual amazing
relationships Ken Coleman Ramsey
personality is my co-host today as we
take your questions about your life and
your money the phone number is AAA
825-5225 that's triple eight eight two
five five two two five just a few
minutes ago Ken and I jumped off the
plane and ran over here to do the show
today we're back in from Phoenix this
morning to wonderful back-to-back sold
out events in Phoenix thank you Phoenix
we appreciate you we love you we
appreciate the turnout it was an
absolutely incredible couple of days
incredible great crowds they got there
early and they stayed all the way
through and in just a tremendous amount
of momentum that you're feeling in the
lives of those people as we get to greet
so many people after the event signing
books taking pictures people are winning
and that's not a narrative you hear very
often and it's exciting to Get Out Among
the people and talk real practical
principles to build wealth where it has
nothing to do with relying on the
government or quite frankly anybody else
and uh it's exciting to see that these
are the Building Wealth events that are
all sold out for this fall we'll be also
in Sacramento in Minneapolis
in San Antonio uh before it's over and
those are all sold out as well there
might be a few tickets to Minneapolis
left I think but it's basically gone and
it's fun to run into folks like you said
this is a of this crowd at Building
Wealth we rented a lot of baby steps
millionaires showing up and uh they're
just there to relearn that the things
they've been doing all these years are
still smart that's right and and you
know it's exciting to see so much
optimism you know it's first of all it's
nice to be out and get into a full room
and the energy that comes from a live
event if you uh hear about one of our
Ramsey live events coming to a city near
you jump on it it's a special special
night and there's something about money
pep rally it is that's exactly what it
is you're fired up even the everyday
millionaires now you know excuse me the
baby's house millionaires even they're
there because they're just like you know
what we're still teaching Financial
Peace University we're leading these
classes and we do it because it meant so
much to us yeah yeah there's a huge move
out there right now well thank you guys
we appreciate you Phoenix We Appreciate
You America again open phone's here
right now at triple eight eight two five
five two two five let's start this hour
with Tyler in Riverside California hey
Tyler what's up
hi thanks for taking my call sure
um so
so my husband and I are in a little
disagreement about where we should
invest our money in the future I want to
invest into
and he want to invest into what your
phone cut out
oh I want to invest in mutual funds
and he wants to only invest into
property because he's afraid of doing
the stock market and everything
so I just want to know like
what how we should go about that or if
we can do both even if we're not very
knowledgeable about it or how I can talk
to him about how it works
okay well investing in real estate
um
unless you have the money to pay cash
for it is not what we would recommend
uh borrowing money to go into real
estate is a lot more risk than anything
the stock market represents as far as
risk goes
um so but paying cash for some rental
properties and having some mutual funds
in your Roth IRAs and 401ks is a great
idea a good mix of that that's what I
personally have
and so yeah doing both would be you know
what if if that's what each of you kind
of your husband has more of a real
estate idea and you have more of a
mutual fund idea then I don't know why
you can't do both is he completely
opposed to putting any money into the
stock market
he really weary about it
um even when I try to tell him how it
works from based on just you know what I
hear from you knowing that oh we don't
have to worry about it we have to do it
ourselves once it's in there for 20 to
30 years we know it's going to be good
but he what is it what is he weary about
he really thinks because it goes up
and that if it goes
it'll just all be bad okay but based on
what isn't going to crash what is he
basing that on because it never has
except except 1928.
Okay so
so she's mine that anything
is one
Anything Could Happen
yeah I really don't know how to convince
him because he's
he's very scared of putting it somewhere
where someone else is moving it and
we're not the one doing it oh you should
be doing it you need to be picking the
mutual funds but just like you pick a
neighborhood
to buy real estate in how old is your
husband
he's 30. what does he do for a living
um he's a bike salesman right now
okay all right so here's the thing
there's two kinds of fear
the fear that is a reality that's like
don't touch a hot stove don't stand in
the middle of the interstate with an
18-wheeler coming at you okay that's
that's fear that's reality and you want
to avoid those kinds of fear the and
that's fear telling you how to survive
right the other kind of figure is false
evidence appearing real and so what it
amounts to us is he's heard his buddies
at the bike shop
who are Financial idiots
talk about how the stock market's going
to crash
and they have no idea what they're
talking about and so he needs better
sources of information he needs to learn
some more because the more knowledge you
have I mean the first time you get uh
behind the first we'll use a metaphor
that works here the first time you get
on a bicycle
when you're learning to ride a bike when
you're four or five or whatever it is
right you're afraid
but then once you've done it a long time
you have knowledge about how the bicycle
works and you're now functioning and so
all he's lacking here is knowledge he's
not basing this from what you're
describing on anything
uh other than a vague feeling
right yeah yeah and you don't need to
make decisions in your life on anything
on vague feelings and so I would just
encourage both of you to continue the
learning process and yeah I would have
some real estate in there if you're
willing to pay cash for it but if you
guys are just now getting out of debt
and you don't have a big pile of money
you're probably not going to be in the
real estate market for a while and
buying real estate on debt is much
riskier than the stock market is you're
asking for it oh and you're doing that
so we tell people not to do that I don't
do that Tyler I would suggest two things
one if you've never contacted and met
with one of our smart investor Pros go
to ramseysolutions.com set up an
appointment and maybe set up two or
three so that he can sit with you in the
office of one of our smart investor pros
and let them answer all of his questions
is my news the minutia to the broad
that's the first step but I also tell
him to go in there not don't buy
anything yeah this is a information this
is a we're going to go to class right
we're gonna and you're gonna do this as
a favor to me right then the other thing
is I'm going to T Dave up really quick
Tyler because uh over the course of 50
60 years what's been the average rate of
return on the stock market a little over
11 close to 12. yeah he's got she's got
to speak in super simple terms almost
the Ross Perot poster board here's the
graph here's what it's done over a long
period of time Simplicity will help yeah
but I mean it's you just learn the
history of something that's right and
then you don't worry about it you know
as much because you're you're then
you're you're
you know facts are your friends
fear is not your friend
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
I say it all the time if you're a
business owner and you don't know your
numbers you don't know your business and
when markets are shifting it's even more
important you've got to know where you
stand so you make your next move the
right move and you don't have to be in
the dark here over 31 000 businesses
including my team at Ramsey know their
numbers because they use netsuite by
Oracle the number one Cloud Financial
system netsuite gives you visibility and
control of your financials planning
budgeting and inventory so you can
manage risk get reliable forecasts and
improve margins having everything in one
place has saved my team hours each week
since we made the switch to netsuite
netsuite is a game changer so head on
over to netsuite.com Ramsey to get a
product tour today that's netsuite.com
Ramsey
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
Coleman Ramsey personality is my co-host
today open phones at triple eight eight
two five five two two five
Susan is with us in Portland Maine hi
Susan welcome to the Ramsey Show
hi Dave good afternoon
so I have a rather I
um so I apologize for my lack of
information but I'm calling about a lump
sum pension uh distribution from my
husband's employer he he so the amount
of the distribution well we're both 65.
I we were both planning on working for
probably another two years but he's been
talking with talking with people in his
work who are retiring this year and who
are planning to retire in 2023 and I
have a question about the withholding
that the
um the employer is I believe required to
withhold from your distribution is that
correct well there's two options on that
one is if you actually take the
distribution in cash and bring it home
put it in your checking account they are
required to withhold 20 and it will be
taxed on your actual tax rate
which will probably be more than 20
what's the lump sum how much is it
something
a thousand little
okay I don't think it's going to go up a
lot okay so here's what you want to do
instead of that
you want to go to your smartvester pro
your your uh investment advisor and
right to a direct
transfer rollover of the lump sum
distribution into an IRA and mutual
funds because you don't need four
hundred thousand dollars in your
checking account right no and there's no
reason for you to pay there's no reason
for you to pay taxes on it right now and
so I would roll it all to an IRA
in mutual funds that you sit down with
your smart investor Pro and pick and
there's no taxes withheld and no taxes
due
when you do that huh
and so they're they're telling my
husband that there is a 20 withholding
there is if he takes it home but he
can't there is a 20 withholding and the
taxes will be greater than that because
you're you're going to have a 400 000
income that year so you're going to have
a 40 tax 39.2 okay so
um you're gonna get hammered so but they
are not required to do that if you do a
direct transfer rollover they are
required not to touch it as a matter of
fact okay okay and then there's no
withholding the entire amount goes into
it exactly it's called a direct transfer
rollover meaning it doesn't come home to
you it goes from one type of retirement
to another type of retirement you're
just moving it around all still under
the protection the umbrella of the
retirement plan so that it doesn't get
hammered by the government
okay and then when you of course when
you do take out anything you take out is
going to be taxed right and you're going
to have required minimum distributions
beginning at 72.
yeah okay so
on okay and is there oh I'm sorry
another uninformed question but there is
there isn't a capital gains tax correct
there's no capital gains at all on any
of this
in any situation it's all ordinary
income it's all your regular tax on your
what your income is and basically in the
future that'll be whatever your income
is plus whatever you withdraw from this
in any year is income
right so when you bring some of it home
from this direct transfer rollover later
like if you pull 100 grand out that's a
hundred grand of income that year
and so but there's no capital gains at
all on it
okay so I already have to have an IRA
account established
you need to go to you need to go to your
smart investor Pro or whoever you guys
work with and and uh you're going to
establish a new one it has to be a
separate new one but it's an i it's an
IU open an IRA then they send the
paperwork from that Ira from that mutual
fund company over to your husband's
company your husband's company sends the
money directly to them it doesn't come
to you don't let them write you a check
right right right I don't want it to
come to me you're right for for the
reasons that that you just stated
correct perfect and um is my is the
employer required to do that is there
yes they don't have a choice they can't
say no this is regulation this is tax
rigs okay and um and you know they may
be ignorant they may be ignorant about
it and somebody has to teach them but um
but usually if somebody's got a big
enough pension that there's 400 Grand in
it they know enough of what they're
doing that they know you can do a direct
transfer
yeah and is there any benefit then to
like retiring this year and taking that
versus working I mean we were both going
to work another two years so
I I if he can take the lump sum next
year there's there's no problem the only
thing is that it when you move this
money it doesn't die when he dies
but a pension dies with him
right oh yes of course so if he if he
wants to work into 23 and then dies
before he gets that money out of there
that's a four hundred thousand dollar
error
and I mean and we both have 401ks as
well so I guess we'll be facing this
perhaps the same situation exactly
you'll do the exact same thing with your
401k when you leave
well I'm
I'm to the smartvest or Pro um people
that you that your site recommended so
thank you I and I and I heard back so I
I was just hoping to be a little bit
informed before before going to them so
thank you so much well they'll tell you
the exact same thing and it's a fairly
standard process and that'll keep a big
chunk of taxes out of uh out of
Washington DC which anytime we do that I
think that's a character thing yeah we
should have a sound effect like a little
show party sound effect anytime we help
a listener or viewer avoid taxes to the
government should be a celebration it
could be some kind of confetti digital
confetti right boy it is with us in
Houston hey Boyd what's up
oh not much yeah
better than we deserve sir how can we
help
uh I had um my wife passed two years ago
and she was looking after all her money
and I got hit with a tax bill of 140
000.
so I put a mortgage on my house it was
free then I put a mortgage on my house
to pay them
and she passed
and I've been trying to figure out I got
I had 2.2 million to start with
in my 401k
but I didn't want to make any movements
on it until you know I got everything
because looking after the money is a
hard job
and
now I have been listening to your show
this is not the time I was just going to
take out a enough to pay this all off I
would but now they're saying is that
right yeah I pay off your house today
you got two million bucks you got 140
000 mortgage I'd pay your house off
today
yeah let's drop down to 107 1 million
seven hundred yeah it'll come back up
I'm not worried about that part I just
want you to be rid of the mortgage how
old are you
I'm uh 66. okay okay are are you
confident about what you're doing with
all this stuff how did you end up with
140 000 tax bill
oh
I worked overseas and I didn't uh
we didn't record something oh okay okay
so I had uh
yes and I should have paid them up front
yeah oops but yeah okay so that but that
was while she was alive
yes sir she looked after all that okay
I'm so sorry that's a hard thing to go
through and then it leaves you half
knowing what's going on or not feeling
confident anyway of what's going on but
obviously you guys have done a you a
wonderful job saving and investing
congratulations on that part uh-huh but
the problem is I get all this advice
from people but majority of them don't
have any money
well I don't need advice from people
people are stupid
yeah you don't you don't do that you
need to get with a good investment
brokerage firm like one of our
smartvester Pros that has the heart of a
teacher and let them teach you to
increase your confidence that changes
everything doesn't it Ken it really does
and I just want to encourage you boy
getting with one of our smart investor
Pros with the nest egg that you already
have and the advice that Dave has given
you you're going to be absolutely debt
free that that investment and that fund
is going to grow now you're going to
have knowledge of what to do in the
future take a deep breath you're going
to be okay and you're going to be able
to get out of this but go see a smart
Master Pro or two or three and pick one
that you feel like you've got a great
connection with and let them teach you
you make the decisions because you're
going to be really clear and that's
going to give you confidence theme for
the hour so far knowledge yeah displaces
fear it's true this place is lack of
confidence true Clarity is always
displaces lack of peace knowledge know
what's going on this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
how'd you guess with health care costs
Rising learn how Christian Healthcare
Ministries can help you make the most
out of your budget visit
chministries.org budget don't worry it's
worth it
[Music]
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality number
one best-selling author is my co-host
today open phones at triple eight eight
two five five two two five Victors in
Atlanta hi Victor welcome to the Ramsey
Show
Victor did I push the button I did push
the button Victor are you there
all right we're just going to put you on
hold Victor and figure out what happened
there Chris is in San Jose hey Chris
what's up
hello how are you all doing thank you
for taking that call better than we
deserve you're welcome how can we help
yes we're in kind of a unique situation
and we just recently moved to San Jose
from Oklahoma and we sold our home there
and we want to follow the baby steps and
listening to the show for a little bit
um but we also want to be able to buy a
house someday we have four children
and we're not sure if we should follow
the baby steps even though I normally
know you would recommend doing that we
have about three to six months of
reserves but my job is not necessarily
very secure because I'm a pastor and
because it's so expensive here it would
put us in a really bad spot if we were
to use the money that we have in savings
to pay off our two vehicles which we
could pay them both off right now but it
would leave us with no savings
we just bought a new van because we have
a fourth child
um so we're not sure how to proceed we
have no retirement to speak of except
for my wife's retirement who's about to
be a stay-at-home mom as well
um based on the situation that we have
four children she has about 12 000 in
her retirement account which one sure uh
what's your income
um make 75 000 per year uh but that's
before tax I'm considered
um self-employed but then I also get
another 2200 per month from a VA
disability why is it why is it not
stable
well just why did you move your family
from Oklahoma City to California to a
not stable situation
I found out more about the finances
after I got here
um I was a full-time student before that
going through college or seminary this
is my first job as a pastor I didn't
understand that we didn't have as much
money in terms of the church and what
we're bringing in and this is the first
time they've ever had two passers on
staff
they already had one on staff
um
so I was not completely aware of how it
could be we're getting by it's been a
year now and everything's good thus far
it's just
I suppose it's unstable in the sense
that
if something went South at all and God
forbid something like covet happen again
or whatever
you know I might be the first one that
gets let go as my fear there so what do
you owe on your cars
we owe a little less than 11 000 on one
vehicle and the one we just purchased is
we owe thirty two thousand we just
bought that one you can't afford that
car pastor
okay you're way overbought on car
that's I look for about a year the
inventory oh crap not buying it
you make 75 000 a year you bought you
got a fourth kid and your mother your
mother your wife told you to go buy a
van and you did but you way over
purchase you put your family in jeopardy
with that with that purchase that
purchase was very unwise and that's me
being kind
okay you need to sell it
and you need to get a van that'll haul
your kids
for about ten thousand bucks
and then let's just pay all of that off
and uh then all of a sudden your life is
stable again the destabilizing factor
here is this van that's what's caused
everything to go on tilt
you didn't have this van situation
you'll be able to pay off the other one
you'll be able to pay off a cheaper van
and still have money left over and you
wouldn't be freaking out
but the fact that you want to pay off
something that you can't afford forty
thousand dollars total Thirty and eleven
and then leaves you with no money and
when the church is also financially
unstable that's a problem now I don't
know how you're going to go home and
sell that
yeah it depends on how new it is and
you've got so much tied up in things
that are going down in value no I mean I
don't know how you're going to sell that
to Mama oh yeah I agree she's not going
to be happy to be happy with this Dave
who yeah who did what yeah yeah well you
guys you guys did an impulse purchase
based on the emotion of a new baby and
moving to a new city that you really
cannot afford
you really really stepped in it
and um you know you guys if if I woke up
in your shoes that's exactly what I
would do and then I would pay then I
would pay off I pay cash for whatever
you buy get this will probably sell for
pretty close to what you paid for it
since you just got it but um you simply
bought something you can't afford when
you have more than half of your annual
income tied up in things that go down in
value it's very difficult to prosper
very difficult and cars and anything
with wheels and Motors goes down in
value period uh and so this is just a
it's you know you guys did a lot of you
know you graduated you from Seminary you
moved you took a new job you're in
California you had a new baby there's a
lot going on so I'll cut you some slack
but uh but you got to go back and undo
this decision yeah and I would just you
know challenge your pastor that you know
this with your training you're in
Ministry you're gonna have to go home
and talk to your wife about this and
this is going to have to be Vision
casting not demands you're going to have
to she's got it's a safety gland and
she's got that desire Glenn and she
wanted that van and you you got the new
baby and she really loves that van she's
probably never had a van that nice
that's a tough battle to fight but the
way you win that is I would literally
take that car payment and I if I were
gonna do this with Stacy I would write
that figure big on a piece of paper this
is what we're paying per month and then
I would just do some simple math times
12 times 24 times 36 so she can see if
we sell this van and we don't have this
car payment anymore look how much more
money we actually have and really speak
to her safety gland I think that's the
best way to do this I really do Proverbs
22 7 says the borrower is slave to the
lender and sir you are feeling that yeah
you're feeling trapped and you know you
are
and that's what did this and so
um sorry but that's exactly what I would
do if I woke up in your shoes and if you
don't do this you have left your family
vulnerable
not the church that doesn't that is that
is in question not the move not you
being called to the ministry none of
those things left your family vulnerable
a stinking van did
so let's just call stuff what it is okay
so that that's what that's what the
danger it's a danger point is what it is
and it without the pressure of that
particular thing this whole situation
changes pretty dramatically Victor is
with it that was Victor no it wasn't I
tried to get Victor a minute ago and I
screwed it up or Victor screwed it up or
who just who screwed it up Victor you or
me
I have no idea
how can we help you but I'll take the
blank that's okay sometimes I hit the
wrong button I've been doing this a
while but I do it sometimes what's up
hey nothing much um so I'm in the
process of selling my house right now
and um I'm not sure exactly how much I'm
getting back but I was just trying to
see is with the money that I do get back
it might be 30 30
000 might be a little bit more
um because we still own the house so um
I was just trying to see what the money
that I get what should I do should I
save it I pay off some of my debt or
where are you going to live
uh I'm actually moving in with my sister
for now
until I figure out a situation uh I
don't think buying a house right now is
the best best idea so and because the
situation in your life
uh yeah okay yeah all right
so for right now you're just kind of uh
reaching for some safety
yes how much debt do you have sir
so I owe 26 on my car
and um if I sell the house that would
take the get off the house so 26 on my
car and maybe like 900 credit card debt
what do you make
uh 55 000 a year
there's a theme Here Ken yes yes
I hear it on the top yeah you know what
I'm gonna say then what am I going to
say
um the car the car
sell the car yeah I would go buy a ten
thousand dollar car with cash and I
would sell this other one and again
you're trying to reach you're moving
you're selling your home you're moving
with your sister because it's life
situation and you need a sense of safety
right now and just exactly like the last
caller this car is stealing your safety
yeah this over purchase on a car so uh
that was the sell the car segment yeah
for those of you just joining us this is
the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
Coleman Ramsey personality host of the
Ken Coleman show where we talk about or
he talks about jobs careers
getting the ability to make money doing
something that you actually like and can
actually make a big difference in he's
my co-host today you've got questions
about that jump in he's right here to
help you and of course we'll talk about
whatever you want to that's what we do
here on the Ramsey show the phone number
is triple eight eight two five five two
two five Ken it is worth revisiting
because we just sold two people's
precious cars
um hypothetically if either one of them
do it
um
not sure either one of them will by the
way uh but the uh
the the the car is the largest thing and
I'm a car person I like cars I'm a
anything with a loud Muffler I'm a good
redneck and so um you know I I I get it
um but cars go down in value they're the
largest purchase
that we as consumers make that goes down
in value and consequently the the
arithmetic tells us
that
uh the car payment and today the average
car payment America is over 700 dollars
the car payment is more of a detriment
to your wealth
your ability to become wealthy then just
about anything else that's exactly right
and and as you point out all the time
you're putting all that time and effort
you just think about the amount of time
you spend at work how much of a
percentage of your overall expenses that
vehicle is and then remind yourself it's
depreciating in value and you're going
to be upside down in it before you know
it and that's what I mean Georgia we
George and I uh co-hosted the show a
week a circle and he showed me this Tick
Tock video we played for the audience
and people admitting with Glee Dave that
they had a twelve hundred dollar car
payment uh one couple said we have
twenty four hundred dollars in car
payments and they were saying it with a
smile on their face like hey it's just
what you're supposed to do and it's
mind-numbing the messaging that goes
into this that you've got to have a
brand new car or a newer car and people
are overspending to your point they
cannot afford it yeah and and it really
let me just tell you what it is okay
is prestige exactly right status you're
right because it's look at my car and
everything else you say about it is is a
justification and a lie completely but
at the end of the day it's Prestige
because a 32 000 van will haul four kids
and so will a ten thousand dollar van
all four kids safely we're not putting
their little lives in Jeopardy right
that's a bunch of crap that's right and
it's not you know well I want something
reliable and all those used cars are
reliable you know what your new car is a
year after you got it it's used yes and
you know it must be about to break down
you must be about to die right now and
by the way kids destroy a new car as
quickly as they do a used car they don't
care they're gonna throw their little
Mott's applesauce containers and their
Cheetos and goldfish everywhere have you
seen it before you must have been inside
Rachel I haven't but I know she's got
three kids so welcome she's got three
kids and she's never kept a clean car in
her whole life oh boy but it's just like
uh man she it looks like a trash hole
and it's like but it's got It's got the
can we see a little bit goldfish are
ground into the carpet you know it's
like oh my God but yeah the the and that
it doesn't matter what you pay for
that's what you're gonna have that's why
boy why buy a brand new van when the
kids are gonna destroy it well it's okay
if you've got two million dollars if you
want to go buy a brand new van yeah but
that doesn't happen very well but we're
talking about somebody making 75 000
somebody making 50 000 the 26 000 car
thirty two thousand dollar car oh man
this is um you know and all it is is you
get car fever
which means your your brain quits
working right and you start you go oh we
have to have something reliable we have
to have something safe and we haven't we
have babies we have to have room for
them all we can't put them in this whole
thing and well that's true that old
thing may need to be changed out for a
different old thing but it's true
um
but listen you're just you're
mathematically saying with that purchase
I intend to stay in the middle class yes
that's what that is it's a death
sentence yeah to your mathematics settle
for it well I'm going to settle for the
life I have to live just so that I can
feel good about myself when I pull up to
soccer practice and my car looks like
everybody else's or maybe a bit nicer
yeah you really nailed it on the whole
status symbol thing well it's even worse
than soccer practice it's the stoplight
oh right at least you know the people at
soccer practice the people at the
stoplight you'll never meet them and the
amount of money you lost while you're
sitting there at the stoplight to
impress someone you will never meet is
astronomical so true I had a young guy
call on the show one time and talk about
how he was in sales and he needed the
really nice car because it went into his
entire credibility and I said let me
tell you something you realize there's
parking spaces in the back of the lot or
around the corner they don't care what
you're driving you're not driving into
the lobby of their building park around
the back
look sharp use an iron you're gonna be
okay you're gonna brush your teeth take
a bath you don't need a super nice car
to close a deal yeah if you do then you
got the wrong deal yeah it's it's a
problem I you know I've I've done sales
most of my life in one kind or another
and I don't recall ever making or losing
a sale based on what I was driving it's
true when I when I first moved to
Nashville years ago and I was in sales I
was driving a Ford Taurus Dave that had
no air conditioning and the the carpet
or whatever you call the fabric on the
roof headliner hey thank you Dave I just
said carpet the car it probably did have
carpet
if there's a Target shag carpet on the
roof but the top of the thing one day
David started drooping yeah and and I
had that Stacy and I were newly married
we've been married two years and I
literally had a staple gun that I bought
recently for household Duty and I fell
in love with the staple gun Jeremy
Breeland one of our leaders here saw
this I got out of the car one day it was
irritating me was it coming down I'm a
short guy and I got home and I went and
grabbed my staple gun in the garage I
went and went
three staples it's fantastic until I
gave it away to a a 16 year old girl in
our church that needed a car but I drove
it for three more years with Staples in
the headline I've done that too get over
it nobody cared it was a great story
actually yeah and you need those stories
to be able to tell your kids someday
yeah Stephen is with us in Cincinnati
Hey Stephen welcome to the Ramsey Show
better than I deserve what's up
giving
um I'm 20 years old and I'm on baby step
3B and I have some close friends of mine
who just recently uh lost their baby uh
that they were carrying and I really
felt led to give them a gift of fifteen
hundred dollars and I know that they're
not that good with money and they're
they're pretty normal when it comes to
debt and being in debt and so I really
feel led to give this to him but I also
kind of want to plant the seed and find
a way to get them on board with your
baby steps and maybe give them my copy
of The Total Money Makeover but I don't
know how to do it
like in a way that's not hey you're fat
here's a diet book and I was just
wondering what your intense advice would
be
you're a great guy that's awesome you're
great man I love you that's awesome
that's very good cool beans
um you know I the thing I learned to do
years ago is I don't have to talk about
them I'll just talk about me
and I don't mean that in a self-centered
kind of way my point is this you don't
need to tell them things about them that
you have observed just talk about you
and just say hey you know there was a
point in my life I was really struggling
with money and I'd done a bunch of
stupid stuff and there was a lot of
stress in our lives in our life and our
marriage and my and all I just worry
about money all the time and uh when I
finally got control of it it changed
everything and uh this book the stuff in
this book is exactly how I did it and I
don't know if you guys need any of that
or not if that if it matters to you or
not but I gotta tell you this book meant
the stuff in this book meant a lot to me
and so I wanted to give it to you as a
gift
I have a follow-up I've been following
your program and your baby steps since I
was a freshman in high school so I can't
really come from an angle where I've
made big mistakes with money which is a
good thing but it was all about the
household you grew up in
oh yeah lots of I learned to blame it on
your parents
and just say you know when I was growing
up Mom and Dad were doing this stuff and
so I couldn't stand the idea of handling
money the stress I saw in our household
when I was a kid and so I started doing
this stuff a long time ago like when I
was in high school this is the stuff I
did and it's kept me from having to have
the stress
same angle but your the point is you're
talking about your story not their story
and you know that's not offensive then
if someone gives me a book and they say
Hey you know I lost a whole bunch of
weight doing this and um
you know and and I feel so much better
and I've got a lot more energy and this
is the plan I used and hey I don't know
if it means anything to you but I want
to share it with you then you can hand
it to me and I may read it I may throw
it away but I'm not insulted you didn't
call me fat
hahaha this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
of your feedback you can be entered to
win a 500 Visa gift card no purchase
necessary take the survey at
ramsesolutions.com survey
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsey show but that is dumb cash is
King in the paid off Home Mortgage has
taken the place of the BMW as the status
symbol of choice
we help people build wealth do work they
love and create actual amazing
relationships Ken Coleman Ramsey
personality number one best-selling
author and host of the Ken Coleman show
is my co-host today on Ken's show he
talks about careers and talks about the
idea of getting a job getting a you know
actually getting employed number one but
then doing it in such a way that that
you're working for people you love and
love working with and making actual
money doing something you care about it
matters a lot it changes the whole
formula doesn't it can it really does if
you think about our relationships and
then our work those are the two most
important things to us as humans and
sadly so many people still think that
work is just something that we have to
put up with I'm just going to deal with
it I'm gonna deal with crappy leadership
or toxic co-workers or just being bored
doing something because it's a good
check because it's the only thing I can
do and we slog through a week just
feeling like well I'm Duty bound and not
realizing that there is a unique
contribution you can make where you get
paid really well and you enjoy your work
and it's possible and you know listen
getting out of debt many times is the
greatest step to stepping into that
dream job because now you have no
limitations and so this all works
together not to mention as you've said
many times your your income is your
greatest wealth building tool so we want
to help people win at work so they're
winning in life open phones you can talk
about that or whatever you want to this
is the Ramsay show the phone number is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five Josiah is with us in New Hampshire
hey Josiah what's up
hey Ken and uh Dave how are you both
better than we deserve sir how can we
help
glad to hear it I'm 25 years old married
and
um debt free and baby step four and
applying for term life insurance so I'm
going through Xander and got uh approved
for 500 000 but I'm wondering whether I
should go with a 20 or a 30-year term my
thought being if we're debt free now
in 20 years I'll be 45 will I have a net
worth high enough to not require that
insurance or should I go to 30 and stay
insured until 55 at which place I can be
more confident that would be that we'd
be there how's your health
health is good um you smoke no uh nope
non-smoker are you obese
nope okay uh I would buy a 20 year
okay now let me tell you how I did that
okay
here's what actually happened with me
knock on wood I've been healthy as a
horse my whole life okay hardly seen the
inside of a hospital unless I was
visiting someone else so
um
what happened was I bought my first term
life insurance when I was your age
and uh I bought a 15-year level but then
what happened was we added kids we added
income
and I wanted to upgrade the insurance
and so I had a choice then of buying yet
a new policy and getting rid of the old
one or just buying additional so like
about 500 000 in your case okay later on
I'm about another 500 000 but that might
be three years from now or five years
from now and as you've noticed it's not
very expensive
doesn't cost much money and so what's
going to end up happening is you're
unless you lose your health along the
way your ability to get insurance you're
going to end up adding policies or
buying whole new policies and starting
the clock over
gotcha so you don't need a 30 you're
going to end up buying a series of
policies or replacing the earlier
policies as you want more and more and
more depending on which way the math
works the best and
um then you're going to be in a position
to uh
begin dropping them later or when you
look up in your 45 and you go we're 100
self-insured you just cut the cord on
the whole thing and let them let them
float away
um and so but what ended up happening in
our case was I've added policies uh
every five years or so from 25 all the
way up to 60 not to 60 about 50
something and I kept some policies even
though I didn't need them recently just
swi Sharon wants them
and it really didn't have anything to do
I mean it wasn't like she's not she that
like that policy is going to make the
difference what she eats or not that's
kind of silly but even those policies
are starting to expire now and we're
definitely not going to buy them even if
she wants them I'm done with this so um
we have convinced her that she's okay I
think I've got a acronym for that one
what if Sharon wants it as swi you just
came up with a new One D DC Dave doesn't
care
DDC you're not doing it you're done well
I mean it's it's you know she's okay and
she knows she's okay now that's gotten
rid of the that need but what ends up
happening is you're not buying one
policy that's going to serve you
throughout your entire life you end up
adding incrementally as you go along and
so five years from now if you buy
another 20-year policy or another
15-year policy you just started that
clock over on that portion the other one
when it expires you're probably not
going to renew it you know 20 years from
now that's where I am at you're
describing our journey as we begin to
have kids three kids you added as you
went along yes added as I went along
obviously we were able to upgrade
in-house over time and so sitting with
our smart investor Pro we determine what
that right amount was and I it was like
three or four years ago I just did it
and so that'll probably be the last one
obviously I mean we shouldn't need it at
all and so that you described exactly
the journey that that I'm in and I'm I'm
23 years older than him now but the way
our brains work and I did the same thing
Josiah when I was your age I'm thinking
well if I want to just get a 30 and I'm
done it's over but it really it's it's
more life that comes at you in layers
rather than linearly like well explain
to Young Folks so if they're getting
ready to start a family what you
recommend when you go from a couple with
no kids to one kid or two how you the
whole time I'm just saying you know 10
to 12 times your income because when
you're 25 if he's getting 500 000 then
maybe he makes 50 Grand okay if
something happens to him you know
if she's got 500 000 bucks if she's got
one if she got a little baby she's still
got 500 000 bucks invest that at 10 in a
good mutual fund if it's making ten
percent it would pay off pay out fifty
thousand bucks we've replaced his income
without even touching the principal and
so that's the idea of 10 to 12 times
your income on on you and guys you got
to go to Xander insurance and get a
quote if you haven't done this because
the deal is people are blown away how
cheap term life insurance is and it's
gotten cheaper over the years oh yeah
right I mean I bought some one time at
45 and I came back in my 50s to buy more
and even though I was seven or eight
years older it was cheaper yeah because
the rates had come down because they're
using better and better and better
Actuarial tables that are more modern
and reflect reflect the uh the health
Improvement they were using tables from
the 1940s oh yeah and then they started
using tables from the 1960s and now
they're using tables because life
expectancy has changed yeah and I mean
it's already cheap but if you have the
preferred health designation I don't
know if that's what they call it you can
make a lot of money I like to recommend
this to dudes I dropped weight like a
wrestler three years ago when I did it
super disciplined Dave and I got the
preferred rate and saved got more oh
here's another I'm still safe if you
smoke oh yeah it's double Oh yeah double
yeah double oh that's why I asked if he
smoked or he was obedient yeah that's
right because it's double all you got to
do is just quit smoking and it cuts your
insurance in half oh and it saves you on
all the cigarettes oh and it saves you
on all the health problems yeah and yeah
you and No Quarter Pounders within three
days of taking your blood test there's
some world-class advice Dave right here
on the Range that sounds like that came
from experience this is the Ramsay show
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
I've got it for years I've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds Shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller Shades or even outdoor Shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is here
he talks about jobs and careers every
day number one best-selling book from
paycheck to purpose he's my co-host have
you ever noticed that when you commit to
change in one area of your life it's
easier to make progress in the other
areas met thousands of people along
their journey to Building Wealth who
also did other things like lose 50
pounds or find a career that they love
or overcome Stress and Anxiety what
seems impossible
is possible when you have a smart plan
and a smart plan you turn up the focus
and intensity on your goals and that's
why we're bringing the smart conference
to Dallas Texas on Saturday October 22nd
it is our only live event with tickets
left in the fall here and we'd love to
have you uh the tickets are 35 for
general admission VIP and platinum sold
out long ago and uh there's probably
about a thousand fifteen hundred tickets
left to this it's gonna be about 8 000
folks and it's all day long it is your
top thought leaders in every space Ken
Coleman will be speaking uh from his
number one book from paycheck to purpose
how to find and uh and get the job that
you love making money like you've never
made before it's awesome Rachel Cruz
will be speaking on money of course Dr
John deloney will be there speaking on
mental health and mental Wellness on
parenting marriage boundaries all of
that mixed in George Campbell Ramsey
personality will be speaking as well uh
others I'll be speaking and on marriage
uh Craig groeschel and Amy from Life
Church in Oklahoma City so looking
forward to having you guys all with us
this is Dallas Texas Saturday October
22nd there's not a lot of tickets left
if you want to come out do do come out
we ran into a lot of people at Phoenix
this week who had wanted to get in and
couldn't get in the sold out events
there in Phoenix so don't wait until
you're one of those folks
ramseysolutions.com events and get your
seats today this is the Ramsey Show open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five our question of the
day comes from blinds.com find out for
yourself whyblinds.com is the number one
online retailer of custom window
coverings you get free samples free
shipping
and with the new promos they run every
month you'll save even more use the
promo code Ramsay to get the best
possible deal today's question comes
from Rachel in Tulsa I am currently
doing a survival job and planning to
pursue a career as a ux UI designer I
found a six-month program at a college
for five thousand dollars that would set
me up well for career placement I do not
have anything saved at this point and
wanted to know if it was smart to borrow
the money to complete this program if I
would be able to pay it back quickly the
answer is no it's not okay and you don't
need to borrow let me give you just a
really quick exercise that'll open up
your mind here to how achievable this is
if you need five thousand dollars let's
just take 20 hours a week if you can
work 20 hours a week additionally to
what you're doing and you get a job
making twenty dollars an hour that's
very doable that's not a pie in the sky
example okay based on 20 hours a week at
twenty dollars an hour even after taxes
you're gonna be five or six months away
from making five thousand dollars cash
to be able to pay for this now you don't
have any debt now you're qualified to
get into the field that you want to get
in a field that is very lucrative you're
going to start out doing very well and
have a ladder to make six figures pretty
quickly so you don't need to borrow the
money what you need in this situation I
understand what I'm saying this is very
difficult what you need is some patience
but if you can take that frustration or
that desire to get into this new field
and channel it into some hustle and
really crazy maniacal Focus you can make
that five thousand dollars and I didn't
even mention selling things cutting your
budget but we can get to that five
thousand dollar nugget if you will
quicker than we realize all right you
can drive ubereats and pizza and make a
couple Grand a month yeah pretty easy
yeah uh or more yeah if you work like a
crazy person yeah I just gave a 20 hour
a week again I know and you you kind of
dumb you come to dumped it way down but
if it was me I would do it in about two
months oh for sure I'd go get my five
thousand bucks but here's where you get
five thousand bucks you earn it you
don't borrow it that's the point of this
that's the point of the answer and you
go do it right now and you gear up and
you go okay I want this I want it bad
and I'm willing to pay a price for that
so I'm giving up my Friday night parties
and I'm giving up my Saturday night
parties and I'm going to work
like a crazy person for a short period
of time so I can have the cash pay cash
for this and then go get the job because
let me just tell you these things
there's only one way borrowing money to
do anything works out
is if it works out perfectly
so your your theory here is you're going
to go get this do this new designation
and quickly you're going to make the
money back because quickly you're going
to get a new job that pays more that may
be true but it might not be true
it's possible that doesn't happen yeah
and uh you're counting on it only the
debt thing only works if it works it
doesn't work when things don't work and
most of the time things don't work
exactly like you think they're going to
and this is not a necessary risk no no
you can do this we're not saying don't
go get the thing we're saying go get it
but go get it fast and go you know just
go crazy I mean walk dogs babysit dogs
babysit kids house sit deliver stuff
sell stuff go crazy work six jobs and
knock five thousand dollars you can get
in two months easy yes
yeah you'll be tired that's right but
the tire didn't kill you
you know it you know so that and the
other thing that'll happen is uh when
you go get that degree that way
and you're holding that that designation
in your hand and then somebody wants to
jerk you around uh and not pay you in a
potential job you'll walk from that
because you you paid a price to get this
designation yeah and you won't be you
know we're gonna this is gonna pay off
in other words we're gonna Force this to
be a payoff situation so good stuff good
good question very good open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five Josh is in Louisville hi Josh how
are you
I'm doing well how about you all better
than we deserve what's up
awesome
um yeah so I've got an investing
question for you guys
um my fiance and I just recently got
engaged and are beginning to think about
and kind of plan for
um our marriage uh I know that you all
typically recommend 15 of your income
being invested
um as it stands right now each of us
will get about a five percent match from
our companies and they do both have a
Roth option
um would you all recommend once we get
married that we throw five percent into
each of our company's roths and then
five percent into like another Roth or
throw seven and a half percent of each
of our incomes into each of our
companies uh 401ks
good question now let me clarify you're
saying you will be debt free when you're
married
correct yeah neither neither of us have
any debt and you have an emergency fund
of three to six months of expenses
that's correct yeah and so now we're
starting our 401ks newly or we're
starting our retirement plans newly
married now the way the formula would
work is this what do you make
uh I'll be I'll be within about 60. and
what will she make
uh about the same maybe just a little
bit less okay all right so 15 percent
of 120 000.
okay that's the number you're trying to
achieve I don't care where it lands
it doesn't have to land 50 on u50 on her
let's pretend that your 401k sucks and
hers is awesome
it could land over in hers
okay because you as a married person in
the event of a divorce you're going to
split up the retirement accounts
regardless of who the name they're in
that's how the law works okay so it
doesn't matter whose name it is in uh
what matters is the best the most
effective then how do we parse it out we
use a formula we laughing we call it
rock paper scissors in a way except rock
paper scissors can go different ways
this only goes one way and it is uh
match
Beach Roth
beats traditional
now what that means is we're going to do
all the match we can do because you're
getting 100 ready to return before you
even get started so you said you got a
five percent match she's got a five
percent match you're gonna both do five
percent there and and what does that
amount to well it amounts to three
thousand bucks each and so that is uh
six thousand dollars going in to get
both matches of our 15 percent and uh
you know we're trying to get to what
fifteen eighteen thousand bucks is what
we're trying to get to 15 120 000 okay
now then you're gonna do Roth and you're
gonna look at her 401K your 401k if they
both have good options you could
probably just finish up there and it
does end up being 50 50 that way and
that's fine but if one of them sucks
just go ahead and get the match and bail
after that put enough in to get the
match and put it all in the other one
and if that doesn't get you to your
eighteen thousand then you'll do
individual Roth IRAs and you'll get
there you won't get to traditional so
obviously you get the match first then
do roths of some kind then do
traditional you've got enough Roth
available to you to never get to the
third stage
[Music]
gazelle was made for you the never
quitting non-stopping gazelle intents
with gazelle you can say goodbye to
monthly fees and experience a seamless
integration with every dollar so no
matter how or where you spend you are
always in control and since gazelle is
FDIC insured you don't have to worry if
your money is safe
gazelle the debit card that helps you
spend and save the Ramsay way
[Music]
[Music]
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of Ramsey
Solutions on the debt free stage
Christina is with us hi Christina how
are you good thank you how are you that
was an odd to serve welcome where do you
live we actually live just south of here
in Spring Hill Tennessee oh your
neighbors okay wow a big long drive for
you yeah yeah well good to have you
welcome how much debt did you pay off so
we paid off a hundred and seventy
thousand dollars wow and how long did
that take it took just shy of three
years wow good for you and your range of
income during that time well it actually
is a little different from probably what
you're used to hearing we had one more
family member and so we started off with
about 117 and now it's one less family
member and I'm making around 55 to 75
because part is commission ah okay what
do you do for a living I am an insurance
agent oh good for you yes Dave Ramsey
loving Insurance
we're not mad at all Insurance Agency we
just want you to buy the good kind yes
good for you welcome okay so um uh it
sounds like there's a story here
uh yeah one less family member what does
all this mean yeah so um we started out
a little while back and I guess just
during covid
um uh that one less family member
started making some really funky
decisions and it uh
was a little bit of a break of our
family and unfortunately that just uh
gave us quite the the hard time and he
went in One Direction legally and we
kept on moving forward ourselves wow
yeah
I'm sorry thank you you've been through
a lot of pain uh yeah and actually it
happened during
um my last semester about two years ago
I just got this really strong impression
uh to go back to school and so right in
the midst of my last
um semester getting my Bachelor's degree
um this all happened and then I just
felt God saying no no you can keep this
is this is this is it just keep going
this is the plan and you're going to be
okay so I finished I graduated in May in
a degree in what uh organizational
leadership good for you yeah and where'd
you graduate from Middle Tennessee State
University awesome yeah I had a great
program there and debt free too yeah
yeah I bet you did yes yes and so you
unbeknownst to you uh were getting
prepared for this breakup yeah I had no
clue it was very very sudden no plans no
family arguments nothing a lot of um
silence and the the cool thing I guess
it's cool and not cool at the same time
is I didn't realize how much of our
um Journey we were actually I was
actually doing by myself with the kids
um and because I had a spouse that was
like sure whatever whatever you want
okay fine yeah that that's good so I
didn't have any pushback no fight but I
realized afterwards that I I was I was
running it with my kids alone so but we
did a good job we did a great we're
already carrying it so when you had to
carry it it wasn't you didn't notice
actually no that's totally true um God
was just um directing
and it it lightened the load a lot yeah
yeah and you've got a couple of kids
yeah times three wow so out two
four six six kids wow yeah yeah always
wanted a big family and we we made one
and I have no regrets and they've been
amazing they've been on this journey
with us we put up a uh kind of a
thermometer up on the wall with really
cool chalk and colors and all that and
we just started just filling it up as we
were paying off debt and they were
supportive and my teenage son was
helping babysit while I went to deliver
people's groceries and some of them
helped me to clean offices and just make
everything we could to just pay off all
the rest and it was amazing they they
were literally on this weather with me
it was amazing
I mean you have walked through hell and
you're joyful and bubbly about it it's
great I mean she her your attitude is
amazing thank you quite honestly stunned
uh and I guess the the the only question
that's popping in my mind right now I'm
rarely speechless uh but the only
question that follows my mind is is how
much does the financial piece come into
play
in in in the world you're in right now
well I mean had I not been uh you know
listening to God this whole time I would
have uh with everything that occurred
um I would have no degree we'd have debt
I don't know what we would be doing but
instead I was prepared to be able to go
right into a great job
um one that I love by the way because I
followed a lot of your principles apples
John
and a very very happy and we don't have
any debt no car payment nothing and so I
was able to be able to maneuver us
upward without going into debt because
we needed money and we were like oh my
gosh no more paycheck so that was a big
deal huge huge deal what kind of a
ladder do you have financially now in
this new role
um I'm sorry I don't really understand
how much opportunity for you to grow
your income yes oh I'm sorry bladder of
course yeah
um a ton actually where I'm working I
work for a very very supportive team
that thinks very much like I do and and
we're it's it's amazing but I'm really
good at my job and so they put me in
What's called the aspirin program so you
know give it five ten years and I'll
have my own agency I'm not going to go
into debt for it obviously you're gonna
be crushing it wow yeah yeah it's gonna
be great but it really all came down to
you know when you said before you know
kind of going through hell I'll tell you
um it really shows you kind of like
money in a way shows you what kind of
person you are yeah um you either sink
or swim you either get negative or you
get positive and you just it's it's what
you feel like doing and I we felt like
surviving and having a nice happy life
and not going downward and not digging a
hole and so we did well let me tell you
you have a spine of iron thank you there
ain't no stopping here yeah you're a
force of nature girl thank you I love it
and and you know you're taking the high
road obviously by staying vague and I'll
I'll respect that thank you very much on
all the crap and everything but uh uh
the good news is you just kept smiling
and kept pushing and kept smiling and
kept pushing and and God has rewarded
that so so proud of you thank you you
have to feel
accomplished you have to feel powerful
yeah it really kind of gave that um when
you say spine of Steel and John it
really did because when you get to that
point you don't it's it's not a pride
thing on the wrong side of Pride but
it's more like I can see now that I
really am able to do this and um I was
just uh telling somebody when I was when
we're driving over here you know the
kids are listening to you guys on the
radio with other people's debt-free
screams getting them ready and uh
there's someone talking about credit
cards and I looked over at my son Ben
and uh I was like hey you know some
people really do use credit cards and I
just thought he would be like oh yeah
that's true mom but he was like oh
really and I was like yeah and he goes
oh okay I feel sorry for them but um I
will tell you though we really didn't do
it completely alone we've had a Ramsay
Financial coach uh Mr David
uh Gibbs over here
um he has just stuck with us this entire
way he's been with us almost three years
that's great yeah what a wonderful story
we're very very proud of you thank you
okay what do you tell people the secret
to getting out of daddies oh
um working really hard take every single
side job you can just keep smiling about
it tell yourself this is right and
you're strong no matter what you've got
going on and that's the reason I wanted
to do this today
um to uh single moms to people who have
lived through crap thing people who
think they've got too many kids they
can't do it whatever it is
um that's absolutely Incorrect and I've
got three kids who are special needs and
we we pushed everything everything so
anybody who says they can't that's
absolutely false wow well you just
proved it yeah you just proved it thank
you mic drop wow we got a copy of baby
steps millionaires for you Financial
Peace University one year membership and
total Money Makeover read them give them
away whatever you want to do bring the
six kiddos up on stage let's introduce
them right quick before we run out of
time so what are their names and ages so
just going from top to bottom this is
Daniel and he's 14. Benjamin is 12.
Julie is 11. Joshua's nine Rebecca seven
and Elizabeth is five amazing Christina
and the team from Nashville 170 000 paid
off in three years count it down let's
hear a dead free scream all right ready
guys
three two one we're dead free
oh
wow
Alan you're a young couple 25 years old
making 160 000 a year and you can't
figure out how to get out of debt uh
shut up this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you for joining us America
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today when you're worried about
money it's all you can think about and
that stress affects everything your
family everything until one day you look
up you feel like your entire life's on
fire you don't have to live that way you
don't have to when you have a plan for
your money you'll discover peace even in
the middle of the fire
as you walk your way through it and out
of it just like our last debt-free
screamer in Financial Peace University
you'll learn the simple plan that's
helped almost 10 million people budget
save invest spend wisely get out of debt
build wealth and increase their
generosity
and now the course includes Dr John
deloney George Campbell Rachel Cruz and
me it's the best version of FPU we've
ever done and we're offering at the
lowest price we have ever had to make it
easier
than ever to get started decide today
you're done letting money stress rule
your life get started with Financial
Peace University visit
ramseysolutions.com FPU that's
ramsesolutions.com FPU
Ken uh when I was growing up I went to
uh mom and dad were in the real estate
business and they would take us to sales
conferences and I got to hear some of
the old-time motivational speakers and
later on became friends with Zig Ziglar
before he passed away he was the kind of
the king of that
and uh
you know they talk all the time in that
world about your attitude is everything
and you decide your attitude
and um that last debt-free screamer
was
I mean it's intriguing she's inspiring
yeah I mean it's unbelievable it's
intriguing to me though that the same
set of circumstances come at one person
and they choose
and you do choose
to approach it with one attitude or
another I do this I mean I don't I mean
we all I guess everybody sometimes
something comes at you and you just go
you have a little pity party and it's
like well there's no fear my life is bad
and it sucks and we do that and then
other times you just rise up like she
did and man I just want to be her when I
grow up all the time no question she she
went into I we don't know what the story
was but oh my God it was obviously a
mess and leaves her as a single mom with
six kids yeah and nothing but smiles and
on fire and jamming it and everyone
watching and listening knows she's going
to be okay and you know what that had to
do with not the circumstances it had to
do with her attitude and how she's
approaching it well our values Drive our
attitude I really believe that we still
have to make the choice but there comes
a point when hardship and the unexpected
comes your way and it's really a fork in
the road and so I'm either going to have
a positive attitude and keep pressing on
or I'm going to have a negative attitude
and I'm going to withdraw I'm gonna
retreat and there's an incredible woman
who who her values dictated her actions
and see attitude determines actions and
I think underneath attitude is always
what do I value and here's a lady that
said you know what I got six kids
I there is no option I love these kiddos
we've been on the debt-free journey I'm
not gonna stop it's doable and she
realized I was leading the charge anyway
and so she chose to say you know what
I've still got my six kiddos these these
kids are everything to me God arranged
it to where I finished my degree just as
I needed to Great professional
possibilities Financial culture life to
help her MC coach to help her walk
through this stuff but all these things
she did right and she just looked and
said okay this sucks but there can be a
better future I whispered to her just as
we we took pictures with her I said hey
the best is yet to be and she looked at
me she goes I totally know that I mean
that is the attitude you're talking
about and she's been through some storms
yeah well and and you know the truth is
everybody gets a storm oh we all we all
get up welcome to life in the last two
or three years have been a storm for a
lot of people in a lot of situations and
whatever you know whether it's a a
medical diagnosis whether it's a
relational blow up whether it's a career
blow up a financial mistake a business
error I mean you know or something comes
at you that you don't have any control
over but the only thing you can control
and this sounds so Pollyanna man when I
used to hear these old motivational
speakers I would think yeah bullcrap you
know uh but it's it you know
you
there's nothing that comes at you
that a negative attitude makes better
correct
it doesn't make it go away to have a
positive attitude and a positive outlook
and a way of doing it but and but she's
a stellar example of I'm going to choose
to embrace this and call it all joy yeah
I can hear Zig in my I can hear him in
that classic southern accent that that
kind of evangelist draw you talked about
the attitude of gratitude and you know
she in that moment decided to focus on
what she was grateful for not what she
said this was a message for me and you
it's a message for everybody listening
that uh whatever it is you're facing uh
you know maybe you don't need to look
like you're weaned on a pickle you know
I love that it's true maybe you don't
need to sit around going let's just bed
and you know Biden's the president and
before that Trump was the president and
you know you know it's bad and life is
bad and you know a lot of people spend
their whole existence like that keeps
you stuck in the past yeah it keeps you
stuck period yeah you don't move out
with that one so
um but man and uh it's
so the lesson for everybody listening
and for me out of that is I get to
decide yeah
I get to the side am I going to smile at
this and go this sucks and we're gonna
do it anyway yeah you know or am I gonna
sit on my hands and go my life is bad
and you know there's systemic problems
with the economy and America's just
falling apart it's a horrible place and
I'm proof of that ux that's great you
sound like the guy's had a pickle right
there that's pretty good yeah you know
instead nobody ever does negative
attitudes with a positive enthusiasm
that's the whole point yeah I mean
intonation slows down you know it's
crazy I you know I think we all have to
choose in those moments instead of
becoming discouraged we have to get
determined and I think that's the focus
it's okay all right I'm not gonna let
this overtake me I'm not going to let it
determine my future and you talk about a
a true hero you you call our audience
rightfully so Heroes all the time now
how can you not look at her and I love
that she called out other single moms
and say hey
I'm up here to say you can do it yeah
I'm here to prove hold my beer I got you
yeah that's right this is this is real
and uh that's a real thing so
um deloni Dr deloney John talks about
that all the time that um you are not
your identity is not the worst thing
that ever happened to you correct
that is not who you are
not a product of a negative thing that
happened
I'm not a product of being stupid and
being bankrupt by the time I was 28.
it's just a thing that happened uh did
it did it change me yeah did it change
the direction of my life you bet but I'm
not a product of it I'm not Dave Ramsey
and I filed bankruptcy that's not that's
not my identity it is a thing in the
rear view mirror nowadays 30 years in
the rearview mirror
um more than 30 years and so but but
um you know it's still there there's
still a thing there it's still there but
it's not defining the future I love your
story and I don't want the audience to
miss that you know Dave's obviously
wildly successful now but it's largely
because of the failure you know
successful men and women don't let
failures Define them they learn through
those failures they that when you talk
about that story when everything's
crashing down on you and the shower's so
hot you can barely stand it I mean here
you sit decades later
because you decided to learn from that
and move forward I'll be honest for
about six months all it is around one
well sure and I blamed everybody else I
blamed the president I was just natural
I was the guy we're talking about not
being you know and then a buddy of mine
goes you know you have a whole bunch of
lemons you probably ought to make some
lemonade there you go it's in other
words I'm tired of you whining you need
to go do something with all this and get
up off your your whiny butt and uh he
called me out and you know that was that
I remember where I was sitting in that
lunch with him and uh that wasn't the
only thing that did it but I had had I
just tried whining long enough and it
wasn't working so I need to try
something else well and you're an
example that our failures can refine us
shape us the fire the pounding you know
I love watching The Old Blacksmith when
they take this inanimate iron object and
they stick it in the Heat and it gets
piping hot and it's red and they put it
on the Anvil and beat the stuffing out
of it all to turn it into something
extremely valuable and so you've not
lost your value no that's what we're
saying being reshaped yeah and uh it but
the hammer hurts oh and the fire and the
fire yeah getting there's no fun it's
real it's you know having a testimony is
a wonderful thing getting one's a pain
in the butt this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Dave here we just launched a brand new
audience survey for the Ramsay show and
we'd love your feedback you could be
entered to win a 500 Visa gift card no
purchase necessary take the survey at
ramsesolutions.com survey
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
ERS of Ramsey Solutions broadcasting for
the PODS moving and storage Studio it's
the Ramsay show where debt is dumb cash
is king and the paid off Home Mortgage
has taken the place of the BMW as the
status symbol of choice we help people
build wealth do work that they love and
create actual amazing relationships Ken
Coleman Ramsey personality number one
best-selling author host of the Ken
Coleman show where he talks about
getting the job that you love making the
money that you should make and all
things jobs and career and you got
questions about that jump in he's here
to help and we're going to talk about
your life and your money it's what we
always do the phone number is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Dan is in Scranton Pennsylvania hi Dan
welcome to the Ramsay show
hello Dave and crew thank you for taking
my call sure
so here's my situation I'm 61 years old
I'm going to be 62 in January I'll be
retiring from Corporate America I'm
married 42 years I purchased a home in
Pennsylvania this past April while my
New York home is up for sale and for
that Pennsylvania home I got a 30-year
variable rate mortgage for 495 000 and
it's currently fixed at 2.8 percent for
the next 10 years with a payment of 2700
a month I sold my New York home shortly
after I closed on the PA home so my
question is should I take the 500 000
from the sale of my New York home and
pay off the Pennsylvania mortgage or
should I invest that 500 000 in a
managed Fidelity Vanguard or some other
index fund and use that interest on the
500k to pay off the PA home at least for
the next 10 years and then reassess the
situation because I have no debt other
than that PA mortgage my wife and I
should be bringing home about 11 000 a
month when we retire as I had tension
and I got 1.1 million in my 401k which
is mostly sending in cash money market
now why what should I do why is it in
cash and money markets
um
well you know I've had it invested in
index funds for two 25 years and I've
done well and they're on sale right now
I'm nervous I mean had I had that in
there where the Market's losing 20 this
year so that's what scared me uh I I
dabbled back in about a month ago I put
the 300 000 into the market again split
it in index funds small medium large uh
cap index funds 33 and a third so
I I don't know I don't think the market
hey I'm your age and I think the
Market's on sale I haven't taken any out
and I'm putting money in I think it's a
good buy right now
so you can do what you want to do but I
wouldn't have a million ones sitting on
the sidelines making no money that drive
me nuts
um now what about the mortgage I pay it
off tomorrow
and not use the interest on that you've
asked this question of suggesting I have
the answer six times
um and so you really don't want to pay
off the mortgage you really want to
invest it but let me tell you why I'm
telling you to pay it off okay in our
study of 10 000 millionaires that are
sitting about where you're sitting the
vast majority of them were between one
and three million dollar net worth which
is exactly where you're sitting uh we
found we did not find any of them that
said not one not a single one that said
the way I became a millionaire was
borrowing on my home to invest in the
stock market
none of them said that
and effectively that is your question
isn't it
yeah should I borrow all my home at 2.8
percent and invest in index funds oh
wait I've got a million one on the
sidelines because I'm scared of the
market and I don't think it's going to
do that well you're talking out of both
sides of your mouth
you answered my question
no you're hey Dan listen here's the
thing uh if I were in your shoes and I
and I am in the sense that we're about
the same age
I would be a hundred percent debt free
and I'd get back in the market uh with
the other money and you're gonna have a
great life the sense of peace
that you have when you have zero debt
is not definable with mathematics
e and you've worked your butt off and
you have done a great job of building a
high quality retirement dude you're a
stud you have killed this
and I'm sure I've used your principles
I've been putting 13 of my salary away
for 28 years and you're and you're a
baby steps millionaire an everyday
millionaire you you know you you nobody
gave you any money you're the guy that
got up left the cave killed something
and drag it home you showed up at work
when you didn't feel like it and got
stuff done you got grit you're that guy
that's how you got where you are I know
that about you because I can tell I can
see it in the numbers
you don't get where you are being a
melting snowflake okay you get where you
are grinding
and and showing up and being a man of
honor and a man of Duty and that that's
who you are am I wrong
that's what I did yeah and so and and it
wasn't it wasn't fancy and it wasn't
sexy and all your get rich quick friends
thought you were slow
but you weren't slow you kicked all of
them's butt because here you sit with it
probably about a two million dollar net
worth give or take and and you did it
man so I I want you to enjoy this season
where you've lived like no one else
you've paid a price now you get to live
and give like no one else and not having
a mortgage while you're on vacation
somewhere around the world with your
wife enjoying your 42 years of marriage
um it's it's a different thing man and I
want that for you I want that sense of
peace that sense of power we don't need
to Arbitrage your home we don't need to
leverage your home for you to win you
won
you already won yeah and I love the
advice that you give because I just walk
through that scenario and he's got a
house that's right at uh he didn't tell
us he told us what the mortgage is it's
probably worth more than the 495 way
more than that and so now all of a
sudden with having no debt you have this
asset that's extremely valuable if you
need to liquidate it's there not to
mention he's invested you know and he's
done so much it is no he's not going to
need it but that's the whole idea is not
carry the debt at all this idea of well
I'm going to pay my mortgage off with
the interest what's the temptation to
follow that you're gonna have twenty
thousand he's got eleven thousand
dollars already coming in when he puts
that million one to work and creates
another 10 15 000 bucks a month yeah
he's gonna have twenty twenty five
thousand dollars a month to live on and
have no payments
this sounds like a good life to me
I like your life it sounds like the
American dream and I'm proud of you I'm
proud of you man he's he's who we're
trying to get people to be 100 he's the
poster child yeah yeah
well neither one of us are children
anymore but yeah
she's a post or something it's a
metaphor where poster something's Ken
but we're not sure which you guys are
young still I think you got to get to 80
85 before you can call yourself old in
today's world uh just the older I get
the older my grandpa when he was 80 he
kept talking about this guy down the
street he said that old man and I'm like
Grandpa you're 80. he goes yeah but he's
older than me he's an old man so that's
true no matter how old you get somebody
older hopefully
well at some point you run out of
candidates though
listen that guy Dan Dan you're a stud
man yeah I'm so proud of you and I would
just enjoy this and uh don't overthink
it you didn't get here by overthinking
it you got here by executing steady
rhythm
you stuck with it the grit that's how
you got here just keep doing that
not by trying to get fancy this is the
Ramsey Show
[Music]
all right
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you
that's why you need to get in touch with
Churchill Mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for you that means
they check in every year with free
consultations to help you stay on the
right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
foreign
[Music]
Coleman Ramsey personality is my co-host
today open phone is a triple eight eight
two five five two two Five Guys we
really value the input from people who
watch and listen to the Ramsey show it
helps us know what's important to you
what you like and the things that we
want to change and can change based on
your input we will and uh we we love
hearing from you we're doing a survey
right now it only takes a few minutes
obviously it doesn't cost anything and
those that take it will be in a drawing
for a 500 Visa gift card that obviously
could be used for anything that's a
pretty nice gift so um go take the
survey and you might be the winner of
that ramseysolutions.com survey you can
answer the questions on your phone
really quick won't take but a minute
ramsesolutions.com
survey Kyle is with us in Montgomery
Alabama hey Kyle welcome to the Ramsey
Show
hello Dave hey Ken thanks for taking my
call today sure what's up
well my wife and I found the baby steps
about four years ago and we were
fortunate enough to start on baby step
three uh since then we've taught FPU two
times but we we are still hesitant to uh
cut up the credit cards and close the
accounts uh we have that that fear of
fraudulent debit card uh purchases and
I've heard you talk about it before in
the past about the protections between
debit and credit cards yeah please own
research go ahead go ahead I'm sorry my
own research uh following hearing those
episodes I have uh looked into it and
found anecdotal evidence that people
suffer when their debit cards get
misused and then the banks Hank a while
or they may try to refuse the refunds by
those uh fraudulent charges do you have
any input or any other protections out
there that you would suggest that help
prevent those to help us get over that
fear and stop using credit cards yeah
um
first I would tell you that if you don't
get over the fear you should not lead
Financial Peace University
because it's you're telling you know
we're telling people to quit using
credit cards and you leading the class
or still using them as hypocritical
so that's not good for you it's not good
for the people in the class so if you
can't you get if you can't deal with
this issue I understand I'm going to be
mad at you but it's inconsistent for
when a Cornerstone of the class is to
get rid of all debt so that you can
become wealthy so let's set that on the
table first secondly absolutely I
understand now secondly I carry debit
cards
um and I have used them literally all
over the world I don't own a single
credit card
um and I have had fraudulent
transactions
I've had lots of scares lots of
shutdowns uh lots of reverse charges
um I have never had a bank
uh hold money on me and I'm I'm probably
my point is I'm probably more exposed to
fraud than the average person because I
travel so much and I do so many
different kinds of transactions and we
run all of Ramsey Solutions a 300
million dollar company with debit cards
the company doesn't have any credit
cards and so you know I've got like
several hundred people that work on the
team that carry a Ramsey debit card so
we've got massive exposure to what
you're talking about and our practical
experience is it is so rare
that something takes more than 24 or 48
hours to get refunded that it's on you
know it's there now if you're buying
something
for
an amount of money
that if that amount of money doesn't get
returned to you
in 48 hours destroys your life that says
you shouldn't be buying something like
that
mathematically
and so there's another level of lack of
wisdom that's involved in some of those
stories that you find in the deep dark
recesses of the internet uh in your
research that you've done but the the
Practical fact is we see so little
misbehavior by Banks or stress put on
people by this that it that the offset
of now we'll tell you this the people
that use credit cards and pay them off
every month
78 don't
pay them off every month so someone's
lying
about paying them off every month
because when you talk to people they all
say they pay them off every month and
nobody does and so you know the number
of people that fall into the Trap of
getting screwed over by the use of
credit cards versus fall into the Trap
of having their life considerably offset
by a delayed refund in the rare event of
a fraudulent transaction that actually
does
cost you money and how long does it take
to get back in your account is uh
you know the the numbers don't even I
mean it's a bazillion times more on
credit cards the lives are destroyed and
messed up than they are by somebody not
getting a fraud refund on a debit card
and so the trade-off is not even close
uh yeah there is there is a reality that
that can happen and it does happen on
occasion but it is not a frequent thing
I'm giving you a set example that that I
literally have hundreds of debit cards
yeah I I think the data will show you
Kyle and I think you've done enough
research to know that the numbers would
tell you that it's an irritation this
fear that you have not a Devastation and
uh there's two things you can do you ask
what could you do if you don't have
identity theft of Xander Insurance Stacy
and I have that everybody at Ramsey
Solutions does identity theft protection
is going to help you there and protect
you and then I will tell you I'm not
going to endorse any bank but our
personal bank they're so good with their
security that sometimes the station I
are out of state and we forget to tell
them we're going some throw we just go
to dinner and it'll hit send me a text
your card was discharged your debit card
was charged at this restaurant are you
there are you in Cabo is it yes yes I am
as a matter of fact it happened and so
um I think you've created a boogie man
that really doesn't exist lurking around
every corner does it happen yes is it is
it devastating a number of times that
the number of times that it is an actual
serious financial problem to a family
versus the number of times a credit card
is an actual serious financial problem
credit card it is one tenth of one
percent these no they don't even they
don't even line up they're not even
close they're not in the same
Stratosphere of the damage one does
versus the damage another does yeah not
even close and so the trade-off is just
not worth it on this one issue because
debit cards have a 100 percent fraud
protection that's correct if it is fraud
the bank has to refund it that is visas
policy it is mastercard's policy it is
in there it's a zero liability policy
you can read it in their own stuff and
so the people that say CR and he's not
saying this but the people that say well
credit cards have fraud protection debit
cards don't that's not true it's just
not true he's not saying that by the way
but um to his credit but the uh but but
so for those of you out there your debit
card has the exact same fraud protection
your credit card has what he's referring
to is if you uh went online and bought
something with your debit card and
someone someone stole your identity and
used your account or they picked up your
card number off a false reader or
something on a one of these ripoff ATM
machine things and they take your card
and they go buy something with it and it
shows up in your account and it's 200
bucks the it does 200 does come out of
your account
out of your checking account and then
you report the fraud and the bank has to
put it back
and the number of times that that causes
disaster on a family is almost zero
because A banks put it back really
really fast and B you shouldn't be using
any financial transaction that if it
goes sideways destroys your life that's
correct
period now I'll tell you what does
happen and then people use this to whine
about this as a justification
rationalization for using their credit
cards and this is not Kyle but I hear it
all the time for people that are man
keep my credit card and we keep one open
so because when I travel they put a hold
so when you check into a hotel all right
the one we were staying in the other
night I didn't use my card because we
were doing a corporate thing we're out
there and uh his account was set up with
Omni but uh if I go check into an omni
or whatever by myself with Sharon and me
they'll put a hold on your account for
the amount
so 400 bucks a night 300 bucks a night
200 whatever it is right they're going
to put a hold on that and it might be a
day or two before it comes off but
listen if you can't afford a two or
three or four hundred dollar hold on
your account then you can't afford to
stay in that hotel you should be at home
working
that's you know these are the things you
need to think about and but they're like
yeah they took that 200 down okay it
took three days two days for the harmony
took the hold off of it so that
sometimes does happen yeah but you don't
need to be doing stuff that you can't
afford
that that's the other thing so yeah it's
up to you Kyle you get to the side man
but uh the trade-off for me is obvious
it's a minor irritation versus the
damage the credit cards have done to
American families for decades this is
the Ramsey Show
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Coleman Ramsey personality best-selling
author of the book paycheck to purpose
is my co-host today as we talk to you
about your careers your jobs your life
and your money
jump in if you want to talk the phone
number is
888-825-5225 Christopher is with us he
is in Saint Cloud Minnesota hi
Christopher how are you
I'm doing pretty good see
um I'll just start with my question
first
um considering my situation should I buy
a house now with that being said my
current situation I'm currently a nurse
I'm a nurse that I graduated with my
associates degree of past spring and I'm
also a student finishing my R and the
BSN and I'm also a landlord
um and so I'm kind of like you know with
all these things at play you know we're
working part-time and in my situation
should I buy a house and I know that's
on a whole ton of information okay I got
you so so you're you're how old
I'm 22. and you make how much money
a gross right now being part-time is
about 36 100. okay so you're finishing
up school right now
correct yep uh during the r in the BSN
so I'm currently a registered nurse but
it's a wonderful career path
um now I would concentrate on that I
don't want you to get distracted
I want you to finish school
sure so do that how are you a landlord
well I bought a house with my brother in
2018 and we've rented it out of her son
and it's all paid for
so you were 18 years old
correct
we bought it for well a little
background I used to do construction
before nursing and so we bought a house
that was like 31 000 fixed it up and
then rented it out and then what would
it sell for
probably right now 110 and being in that
location okay
if you didn't own it would you buy it
right now
um no probably not won't y'all sell it
uh because we're renting it right now I
guess
it's a single family yeah single family
home so when's the lease up
uh it would be I think in December if I
remember correctly okay
I would consider putting that house on
the market after the first year and
getting rid of it here's the thing I
don't think that house
although it was a neat experiment for
you an experience to do that at 18 years
old I don't think that house is the
secret sauce to your future nor is home
ownership at 22 the secret sauce to your
future I think the secret sauce to your
future is you finishing this nursing
path that you are on you are going to
have tremendous opportunity to make a
lot of money and stay steadily employed
the rest of your life as long as you
want to be a nurse I mean this is an
incredible field there's such a shortage
and Ken the upside's really strong
there's a lot of upside for you uh as a
nurse even if you want to go beyond that
after a while and I would agree with
Dave here the houses are still going to
be there you're 22. you've got this
investment property that you could
absolutely sell take your portion of the
profit and that becomes a part of your
down payment but I wouldn't be in any
kind of Rush I'd get through school
let's get in nursing let's get settled
let's get our sights on where we want to
go within nursing what that Mountaintop
looks like the houses will be there
sometimes Christopher people Miss
achieving a major goal in their life not
because the goal was hard but because
they got distracted and added too many
other things on their plate
and that and home ownership and
landlording and all that other crap
while you're just trying to get through
school I'm trying to clean up your plate
and just say focus on what really
matters what the real goal is and these
other things could just be devilish
distractions
Evan is with us in Albany New York hi
Evan how are you
hey guys how you doing better than we
deserve sir how can we help
yeah so um
me and my dad well he owns a business
I've been I've been only working here
for two years now but he's he's been
relapsing over the past year relapsing
relapsing sorry in what way I mean
in a drinking problem way and okay so
he's an alcoholic
yeah he's back in the bottle we're
trying to run the business
yep wow I'm sorry
what's the business
say again sir what is the business
yeah it's a um Pest Control business
pest control and how old are you
I'm 20. and how many employees does he
have
uh almost 40.
and uh you're 20. how long has your dad
been drinking
um on and off for the past
15 20 years your whole life
yeah
and you've been running around trying to
clean up his message your whole life
uh I'm sorry yeah I'm sorry
that's hard
so what's your question Evan
I'm just
well the bottom line is pretty much like
how do I get them back to work he's kind
of bed we're in right now yeah
um your mom gone
um divorce divorce yeah yeah no kidding
not shocking okay
um has he put you in a leadership
position or are you just one of the
employees who happens to be his son what
kind of responsibility do you have for
the business
um I I do have some responsibility there
I'm one of the managers of the member of
the budget and advertising and billing
but we have like five other managers who
thank God know what they're doing and
are very good okay so the business is
doing well despite his absence
let's just stop let's just stop okay the
um the advice I'm gonna give you is
going to be very hard to hear are you
ready to hear it
yep okay
um there's a whole syndrome around adult
children of Alcoholics
you can look it up and start reading
about the symptoms of an adult child
that grew up in an alcoholic home
and one of the things that we see folks
that grow up like you've grown up is you
you've seen so much pain and there's so
much disaster in the wake of all the
alcoholism that you you feel like your
job is always to clean up the messes
and that's a standard reaction to this
situation
if you were
my little brother if you were my nephew
if if if you and I could sit down
together in a cup of coffee I could put
my arm around you and give you a hug I
would right now and I would tell you
that it's time for you to stop saving
your father
he's going to have to do that himself
you can do that as a loving son from a
distance but if I were you I would go
get a job somewhere else and build a
life somewhere else
and from a position of strength
emotionally and spiritually begin to do
some healing from what all you've been
through
and from that position of strength maybe
you can give your dad a little bit of
aid with his alcoholism but it is not
your job Evan at 20 years old to save
your dad from the mess that he has made
for the last 15 years and that includes
his screwed up business life
you don't have that's not your job I
want to set you free from that
assignment it is not your assignment a
run please run for your sake
you know I I don't know if you'll do
that or not I don't know if you can hear
me say this or not but you need to be
free of this and it doesn't mean you
never speak to your dad again it doesn't
mean you're mean to your dad it doesn't
mean you're unkind to him or that you
yell at him because he's destroyed
everything with his drinking I'm not
telling you to do any of that I'm just
saying you have to have some separation
and go get some healing on your own
because dude what you have lived through
as a child has one is wounding
it's and you know and the one of the
biggest symptoms is that adult children
of Alcoholics have to have everything
perfect
they have to have everything perfect
because their job was to keep up
appearances because Dad's laying in bed
drunk
and so my job is to go down and run the
businesses if he's not and it's it's a
form of denial and it comes out
specifically in this and I'm not a
psychologist Dr John deloney you might
want to talk to him uh I'll put you on
hope Kelly I'll set up a time talk to
him on the air if you want he'll tell
you the same thing I'm telling you
though you've got to have some
separation from this situation in order
to be of assistance to your dad
and it is not your job young man
to fix all this
be free
it's not your job to fix this you didn't
break it it is not your duty to fix it
and you're not a bad son
by walking away from this the best thing
you can do for you and for your dad is
to walk away from this and then you can
give him Aid as a loving son from a
little more distance in a position of
healing please go work somewhere else
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
therefore prepare your mind's fraction
keep sober in spirit fix your hope
completely on the grace to be brought to
you at the revelation of Jesus Christ
Mark Spitz said if you fail to prepare
you have prepared to fail
that's a name I haven't heard in a while
yeah Mark Spitz Olympic swimmer yeah is
that right okay well I was challenging
multiple multiple multiple gold medals
before there was Michael Phelps yeah he
was the guy all right all right he was
the guy wow that's a long time ago
though uh open phone's at triple eight
eight two five five two two five k is in
Raleigh North Carolina hi Kay welcome to
the Ramsay show
hi thanks Dave
um going along with the theme here today
I think of car uh questions
um we have gotten ourselves into quite a
bit of credit card debt over the past
year and
um I'm wondering
um we are doing the plan right now and
we're very gazelle intense and we have a
lot of stuff that we're selling my
husband's income is getting ready to go
up in December and he's also getting
ready to get quite a few bonuses
um in the next couple of months and I'm
wondering if we could wait for some of
that stuff to happen and continue to be
gazelle intense before we think about
selling one of our cars or if we should
just do it now and then you know
whenever that extra money comes in I
guess it's just extra money
okay why are you selling the car
to pay off
hey Austin oh
I see okay so what what is the car the
cars worth what are they worth
we have a
the paid off that probably right now is
worth about thirty thousand dollars
um in my car and then he drops that paid
off
um he actually yes quite a bit I mean he
doesn't it's not a daily driver also
it's a third car it's a third car
it's a third card okay so you have a
thirty thousand dollar third car and the
second car is what
it's worse probably right now about 35
to 40 and it's paid off okay and what's
the next car
the next car is we do have a loan on
that for 30 000 and it's probably worth
right now about 40.
okay and so it sounds like you have a
hundred and ten thousand dollars worth
of vehicles
yes and what is your household income
okay
um well I mean the rule of thumb that we
use is to not have too much tied up in
things that are going down in value and
our definition of that is when you have
more than 50 percent of your household
income tied up in things with wheels and
Motors then you've got too much tied up
and things are going down in value it
makes it mathematically hard to get
ahead you are you guys are car poor for
sure now if you've got a hundred ten
thousand dollars worth of cars or a
hundred thousand dollars worth of cars
and you make 200 you're right on the
bubble on that okay so no I would not
sell those cars based on that formula uh
the other formula we look at is can you
be debt free except the house
if you keep all of these things in 24
months
so you have fifty thousand dollars in
credit card debt and you have uh forty
or thirty thousand dollars in car debt
that's eighty what other debt do you
have not counting your house
nothing okay so can you pay off 80 in 24
months yeah you probably can
so if you love if you love these cars I
would keep them but and but I also want
you guys to look at each other and go we
were right on the bubble on stupid
and we don't need to get up on this
bubble again
okay because you don't get rich buying
cars
no and and you guys have invested a
large chunk of your lives in cars and so
they're right on the bubble and if you
love all three of the cars you want to
hold them you're going to be in a
position shortly to have kept them and
that makes sense mathematically but you
really have to address
um your addiction to automobiles because
you're going to struggle if you don't
that that's the whole process
so
um hey but you're you're right there I
I'm with you I would probably keep them
and I'd probably pay them all off but
the only caveat is just go you know if
we hadn't had these big raises we'd be
selling some stuff oh yeah and they're
still gonna have to hustle yeah we're
gonna have to get after this you know I
I like classic cars in this situation I
was very I was I was surprised a little
bit not at your philosophy but I'd move
one of those cars if the classic car
means a lot to the guy I would downgrade
in my everyday driver to be able to pay
off the classic car that's me that I
would want to fast but I want to fast
forward everything yeah I don't want to
struggle when I can make one train yeah
80 000 bucks and you got you know you
got 24 months yeah so you're going to do
beans and rice in order to keep these
cars is it really worth it to me it's
not what happens a lot of times is when
people get into that they get about they
get about six months into it and they go
screw it sell the car that's right
you're right they end up at that
conclusion and but you know because
right now in this conversation we love
these cars oh yeah but once you start
figuring figuring out this is killing me
I'm having to live on nothing I make 200
000 a year I'm living on nothing these
cars on me yeah and you'll dump one of
them then yeah I agree that's what will
happen but uh it doesn't always happen
but it can't it can it can uh up next is
James in Knoxville hi James welcome to
the Ramsey Show
how's it going better than I deserve
what's up
so I had
I had a camper that I have been going
back and forth with um with my wife on
um I feel like we should sell the camper
um I don't feel like it is a a bill that
we need to keep paying on every month
um how much
about 25 000. what will it sell for
man prices have gone up on everything I
think I could probably get 35 for it
okay and what's your household income
65 000. sell the camper
that's what I feel like they're trying
to convince my wife is a bit tough yeah
with what you're spending on this camper
you can stay in the freaking Ritz
yeah yeah and they'll let you sleep in a
sleeping bag out on the balcony if you
want
it'll make you feel better I don't think
that's true the other thing too is you
know you got to pay for uh you know
diesel fuel to get where you're going
yeah I feel like it's stupid you are you
are paying Rich money for camping
but why does she love it why why do you
think if she hasn't articulated it what
do you think is the reason she doesn't
want to sell it
well we talked about it last night
actually uh he feels like
um you know our kids are young yeah and
if we sell this camper because and we
don't have any other debt beside this
camper in our mortgage
um so you know if we get rid of this I
think she feels like she's missing out
on uh I don't know totally get it all
right so what's your monthly payment to
the uh camper right now
about 425 yeah cast another Vision yeah
at 425 a month that's going to be Memory
after memory after memory but zero
stress I just think you got to replace
her feelings I understand what she's
feeling I think she's right doing stuff
with the kids would be really cool for
400 bucks a month you can do a lot of
stuff and just replace the camper with
another Vision yeah where are we gonna
go I mean go stay in some rustic cabins
go do some stuff that other people own
and you don't have to screw with it it
doesn't sit in the backyard going down
in value and um and it's not it's the
only big payment you have and so
um yeah you guys you guys didn't buy a
camper you bought a dream of family time
while the kids are little and doing
stuff she'll go live that dream Ken's
right a different way and uh that
doesn't involve owning the stupid thing
um and I'm not against campers but
honestly 25 000 camper when your
household income is 60 000 is out of
control
that's just that's a lot of money uh and
so
I wouldn't do that I just I wouldn't do
it I mean I I you're better off to just
spend the money on a hotel spend the
money on rustic cabins whatever you want
to call it whatever the adventure is but
go on different Adventures that are with
the similar amount of money being spent
and
um that that are accomplishing the goal
that she wants to accomplish I'm not
arguing with her goal I think her goal
is valid yes well she's a mama and they
they want to have some great memories
and you can do that and I think you
should we've done a lot of stuff with
our kids as they were growing up and
it's that you know some of those stories
they still talk about them as adults the
stuff we did when they were little and
yeah you got to drag them around and
make them uncomfortable that's part of
the program yeah I think you should get
the whole family really nice sleeping
bags and try that Ritz plan that Dave's
talking about I want to see how that
works out
come on kids we're going to the rich
balcony all right all right smart alec
Ken Coleman James Ben Zach and Austin
and Kelly in the booth I am Dave Ramsey
your host will be back with you before
you know it in the meantime remember
there's ultimately only one way to
financial peace and that's to walk daily
with the Prince of Peace Christ Jesus
Dave here we just launched a brand new
audience survey for the Ramsay show and
we'd love your feedback you can be
entered to win a 500 Visa gift card no
purchase necessary take the survey at
ramsesolutions.com survey
[Music]